mila kunis debuts a new trendy hairdo  and we are loving it right now that the  bad mom star is looking summer ready  after chopping off her long locks into  this sheep bob the mother of two kept  things casual while running errands with  her and Ashton Kutcher's two-year-old  daughter Wyatt 33 year old Mila sported  trendy Sonny's a white tank top and  denim overalls during a shopping trip to  Target on Monday  the brunette beauty's new hairstyle is  definitely on trend in Hollywood this  summer other stars switching it up from  their longer hair bella thorne going  short and pink lindsay lohan rocking a  blunt cut bob for her upcoming role in  the British comedy signal lena Dunham's  dramatic buzz cut and taraji P Henson  revealing her natural curls with an edgy  mohawk Oh  you